good morning everyone good morning it's
so it's gone 10:00 um welcome everybody
to the Joint planning policy committee
on the 13th of October uh my name is
Shan Carney and I'm the head of
communities in place here at torage and
my first task this morning is to seek
nominations from Tores District Council
for a chair for the meeting
please okay thank you so we've got a
proposal and a second can I take those
in all in favor
please and hands again please sorry for
in
favor okay
any
abstentions any
against okay thank you so I'll now pass
over to councelor Hicks who will take uh
nominations for a vice chair from North
Devon thank
you oh and can I remind everybody this
morning when speaking can you press the
green button the speaker button on your
speakers there so that the uh your
voices can be picked up on YouTube thank
you very
much
right thank you ladies and gentlemen for
that apparent vote of
confidence I hope I can justify the
appointment first item appointment of
Vice
chair councel
room yeah could I uh nominate councelor
Malcolm prous
please and seconded any other
nominations show of hands please for
councelor Malcolm
PR that seems to be unanimous to
me proper
job item three oh come up here marcol
there's a seat for
you no not
particularly
right next item is apologies for
absence thank you chair apologies from
counselor Knight counselor K
substituting councelor Bell councelor
Walker substituting councelor Krab
councelor hack it and councel a leather
substituting thank
you right now the
minutes Pages 3 to
10 of the meeting held on the 17th of
March I will take them
from the bottom one which says page
three
yep
correct that needs
correcting right page
four
five
7 8
nine yes councelor hes um was reference
to LC whip here on page nine is it
um could it be made a bit clearer that
the LC whip was only available for the
barille bidford and orthern
areas uh just to make it a bit
clearer covers Bible bord and Northern
com down rather than putting like that
in a
minute surely that comes as the fourth
bullet point under active TR travel yeah
that's that's right
yeah basically it covers baral bord
northern
areas um well okay um surely that's what
it should be
doing yeah yeah okay I won't push it
it's just to make it a bit
clearer okay right all in favor of those
minutes please
show oh so I proposed and I proposed
from the chair seconded counselor James
all in favor please
show
six those
against
none
[Music]
abstentions seven I think that's
somewhere about
right
um right now agreement of the agenda
between Parts one and two there's
nothing for part two as I see it so we
don't have to worry about that
one declar ations of Interest you're all
pretty senior counselors I think you
know the
score if I had to read the book out now
it's rather
pointless item seven items brought
forward as a matter of urgency I have
none so we come to item eight review of
the north Devon torage local plan Pages
11 to
25 senior planning officers are going to
speak on this one here we
go who's going first okay thank you
chair right thank you good morning
members so this is the review of the
north Devon and torage local
plan um if you move move on to the next
s please Ian thank you so set out in the
report legislation requires that a
review of the local plan must be
completed every 5 years starting from
the date the plan was adopted
as the local plan was adopted on the
29th of October 2018 the council's need
to complete this review by 29th of
October this
year this report provides members with
the information required to make this
decision before we go into the details
of the plan review I would I would
stress the importance of distinguishing
between the decision of this
fiveyear review as required by the
legislation show on the slide at and the
subsequent and the separate matter of
the decisions by both councils on the
form of any subsequent updates to the
local plan so this is a separate issue
if we move on to the next slide
please
okay if we look look at the general
principles when I undertaking a review
there are three key points to bear in
mind firstly it is a method to ensure
that a plan and its policies remain
effective that is are they still fit for
purpose this is both in terms of
conforming with national policy and also
local objectives secondly the work
undertaken for the review should be
proportionate to the issues in question
therefore targeted evidence is just as
effective as seeking large amounts of
information which not necessarily
relevant to the issue and finally please
do keep in mind that the policies do not
automatically become out of date after
five years policies will only be deemed
out to dat if the conclusions of the
reiew assessment show that they are
which will'll come on to so if we move
on to our next slide thank you
so this slide shows the issues which
have been considered in the review I'll
go through them quickly so firstly
Conformity of national policy do the
policies in the plan still conform with
national PL the national planning policy
framework and also any relevant written
ministerial
statements um although the plan was
adopted in 2018 the local plan inspector
examined it against the 2012 National
planning policy framework and therefore
this is an important consideration for
our review as there have been updates to
the mppf since since since then secondly
changes in local circumstances for
example significant changes in corporate
priorities of councils are set out in
new adopted strategies and
plans um thirdly demonstration of a
five-year land Supply if a local plan is
unable to demonstrate this then it would
be considered to be out of date for the
purposes of the review and I'll will
come back to that one deliverability of
key sites this means is there evidence
to suggest that a lack of progress on
these sites May Prejudice the delivery
of housing key infrastructure or other
spatial
priorities um appeal
performance if we had a high number of
appeals allowed this may indicate that
there are likely issues with the local
plan policies as they are um
cross-boundary issues do our neighboring
authorities or any of our statutary
consules who we engage under the duty to
cooperate do they have any valid and
relevant concerns relating to the plan
and finally changes to social
environmental or economic
priorities um in the
area I.E are key matters which haven't
been addressed through the local
plan um and if we move on to the next
slide okay so this review is based on a
range of
engagements and evidence which is
presented through the completion of the
planning advisory service local plan
review toolkit the toolkit is designed
to exist local planning authorities in
reviewing their local plans so it's
standard format which all councils can
use um it's split into two
parts part one which is included
appendix eight of this report helps us
to understand which policies may be out
of date for the purpose of decision
making or where circumstances may have
changed um and also whether or not the
policies in the plan continue to be
effective in addressing the specific
ific local issues that are identified in
the
plan so to assist with answering the
questions in part one of the talk it
part two which is appendix B to the
report provides a checklist of the
principal requirements for the content
and form of local plans against the
relevant paragraphs of the
mppf
um as detailed in the report drafts of
the court of the toolkits were presented
to this committee earlier this this year
um this report details the matters which
are outstanding at that time so and the
outcomes of the subsequent work which
has now been undertaken to complete the
exercise of particular notes are three
three matters which are on the screen
these are the establishment of a 5-year
housing land Supply position as
mentioned earlier this is necessary to
demonstrate but but the local plans up
to date um a new housing land Supply
position statement was published in
April this year and then then was
immediately challenged for a planning
appeal uh thankfully the the appeal was
dismissed on 11th September with the
inspector concluding that a 5year land
Supply could be
demonstrated secondly um duty to
cooperate
engagement
the councils have engaged over the
summer with our prescribed duty to
cooperate bodies um these include
neighboring local local
authorities um and some statutory
consulties such as Natural England and
the environment agencies the questions
which were asked are listed in paragraph
4.15 of this report with their response
is shown at the end of appendix a in a
separate appendix one
there were a range of positive comments
received alongside matters which
officers consider have already been
included in revie the review or could be
addressed in the future plan but are not
required to be updated for the purposes
of this
review and then finally offic officers
made additional changes where more
upto-date information is available um
for example we've updated the number of
housing
completions to 2023 base date and
reflected other changes such as changes
in the council
administrations so if we move on to the
F onto the next slide please always
wanted to say
that um the conclusions of the report
are shown on the screen excellent
um basically the plan remains broadly
sorry the plan broadly continues to
provide a robust basis for decision
making however we have identified three
issues where the plan is silent silent
and cannot be addressed by the decision
maker um simply referring to the MPP ppf
so these
are firstly first
homes um first homes are a type of
affordable housing which was introduced
through a written ministerial statement
a couple of years ago um the plan is
silent on first homes so this is a
matter which needs to be addressed
however I should it should be noted that
the policy wasn't included in the
revised mppf
consultation which happened at the
beginning of this year and we've yet to
see the results of um and a government
Minister stated earlier this week um
that the policy may not it's a policy
they may not continue with in the future
but at this point in time it is an issue
which needs to be considered as part of
the five-year review secondly the
revision of traveler sites the local
plan emitted allocating traveler sites
due to not having the
evidence of what the need for the plan
was into a late stage of local plan
preparation um therefore the councils
councils have committed to
to Preparing a separate development plan
document for the provision of traveler
sites and while early work was
undertaken this hasn't been taken
forward in a policy document to date and
then thirdly Coastal change Management
areas um the local
plan sorry the MP plan should identify
Coastal change Management
areas um and any area likely to be
affected by physical changes to the
coast and be clear as to what
development will be appropriate in such
areas in and in what circumstances and
then secondly make provision for
development and
infrastruct that needs to
be relocated away from those areas so
initial work has been undertaken on the
preparing the policies to address the
requirements however at the moment this
moment in time again the local plan is
silent on this matter and this needs to
be recognized in the review so therefore
the conclusion of the fiveyear review is
that a partial review is required to
address these
matters um in addition it's also
acknowledged that there are a range of
matters raised by The Five-Year review
which could be addressed through the
next version of the local plan but that
as I said it beginning does not fall
within the scope of the five-year
review um and
and yeah that's that's that one and if
you want to move on it Ian to the final
slide there you go this sets out the
recommendations of the
report do you want me to read them chair
no I think uh
generally members can read all
right
right who's going to come in next
Helen I think it's then whether there's
any questions or discussion around
around that item then then officers
would be happy to answer councelor
leather tor
thank you chair I'll bring up the
traveler sites one again I see it's
plural on there traveler sites not site
are we are we looking to put more than
one site or try identify more than one
more than one site and I've still asked
and never found out yet what the
evidence you mentioned evidence that we
need a travelous site in the
area but are we are we looking at more
than one site are we considering more
than one site it says s yes yes chair so
the evidence was in a Devon wide in May
correct me if I'm wrong in a Devon wide
um traveler assessment which was
produced in
Ian it's it's a while ago um and for
North Devon in torage it sets out that
there's a need for 15 per
pictures across the plan area plus two
Transit
sites so that's that's where the
evidence comes
from well I'll just mention I don't I
don't know what that evidence is based
on you know what because in T I know
certainly in torage there's not much
demand at
all it was the EMA need to assist me
with this one sorry yeah I could come
back on that if that's okay um so it was
a a comprehensive assessment that um
looked at the numbers of pitches and
plots of accommodation that existed at
the point of the assessment within
torage and then did a forward-looking
sort of demand analysis including
interviews with those that are on those
existing sites to project forward the
likely need for pitches and plots in in
the future and then in terms of the
transit accommodation
um which is the the temporary stopping
places uh it looked at where where the
most Transit activity occurred across
Devon and identified the need for a
number of Transit sites across the the
sub region uh including a suggestion
that um because we had quite prevalent
activity in North ever and torage that
there would be a need for that Transit
site provision across this area as
well I can certainly uh pass pass a copy
of the assess M to council Leather by
email after the meeting if that would be
helpful okay yep councel
Lane
you so so chair if I can come back on
that um so it's 15 plots of pitches of
permanent accommodation that's for our
resident population of gypsies and
travelers um who tend to be on small
rural sites and no in in North de and
torage that's across North EV and torage
uh and and it tends to be for for their
family members who may be the younger
generation who are growing up and want
their own own
accommodation um and then the transit
provision is is separate to that uh and
that's about recognizing that Tor we we
under North Evan we only have tolerated
sites rather than uh official Transit
provision councelor hes yeah so pitches
you mean individual families not sites
is that what you're saying yes so you
you could have more than one pitch on an
individual site it's effectively a an
area of land that's sufficient for a
family councelor
Pro
don't chair um we we we've really KCK
this with in the long grassp for a long
long time um we were criticized in the
local plan process last last time for
not taking this further what I was going
to suggest and I think you know one of
the big debates we've had over these
last couple of years is particularly
ownership of local plans so I was going
to suggest that we put the item formally
on the next agenda with the report so
that if there are any up and it's 7
years old and I think members need
convincing that the evidence is sound
but we just got to get on with this um
we can't avoid it the Govern the
government will force us to do it of any
shade um and if we're going to review
the local plan without do without a
timetable for this as a supplementary
document then we're going to get on
Knuckles wrapped anyway so I was going
to suggest we put it on the agenda um to
decide a whether the the the evidence is
still good enough and sound
and then secondly to agree an action
plan to to address
it makes sense to me um I haven't got
your name sorry Walker celor
Walker um I this is anecdotal evidence
but um we had a group of Travelers move
into playing fields in fing Flemington
Parish um in the summer around the same
time as the group moved into
bitterford we because we had the
Toleration site in in North Devon they
moved on within hours to the Toleration
site um which says to me that these
sites work so I think they're definitely
worth um
pursuing councelor
James thank you chair well I was just
going to say um I I'm Happ with what
Malcolm suggesting um from our side I
think that will be part of when we look
at the new local plan if that's what we
decide is a committee but this the
fiveyear review is a legal uh
requirement um to say that we've
reviewed it I think we can honestly say
well some can honestly say it's been fit
for purpose in the past I think we've
come to a stage now we Mo need to move
on so I would recommend that we adopt
the report that um that as it is that it
it has been reviewed that it has
established in the past it has met the
requirements mostly um and if we are
going to do a new local plan that those
points will all be covered within the
new local plan so um I'd like to move
that we adopt the plan uh the review as
Illustrated CH I'm going just be my
understand we're going to have to do
both those things and we're going to
have to review the existing one as well
as starting if we were going to start on
the new one we still got to do the
review
anyway your mic sorry sorry say can you
say it again yeah my understanding I'm
picking up what Ken James has said is
that I think we'll end up having to do
the two in parallel we we've from a stat
Duty we've got to update our existing
one or review it so you know we'd have
to do that and you know so we'd have to
pick up those ISS issues within the
review um and then you know we can carry
on with the other work in parallel don't
we that's where I understand
it yeah chair I think I think for the
purposes of the item in front of you
today it's it's about the review um and
about signing off that formal stat two
review of the local plan and then as we
know there decisions and discussions to
go forward on on the update to the plan
um and and that's a matter for for
another day almost um beyond the
recommendations that are in front of in
that
report okay yep councelor room I'll
second all the recommendations set
itting
2.1 of the
report per that's councelor James's
proposal and I've got no one else
wishing to speak no other proposals can
I put it to the vote then please that we
accept
that in accordance with item 8 and the
recommendations therein those in favor
please
show that is unanimous thank
you right we now come to item
nine responses to the government
consultation on plan making
reforms Helen you dealing with this one
no it's Ian Roland Ian again yeah thank
you thank you chair this one's this
one's over to me um so the report is on
pages 126 to 152 of your agenda that's
if you're looking at the Tor version um
there is discrepancy with the page
numbering across the two agendas that
were published at North EV and torage
and we do apologize for that it's 127 to
153 if you're looking at the agenda
published from the north Devon side so
the report is to look at the response to
the government's consultation on plan
making
reforms um this follows a lengthy
Journey that the government is on to
reform the planning system more widely
that started uh through a white paper
that was published planning for the
future back in the summer of 2020 you
may recall and they're progressing the
reforms through a series of
consultations through legislative
changes and through a series of policy
changes as well um and there's been a
number of consultations that have have
have supported that the planning for the
future white paper had a consultation
back in the summer of 2020 we had a
further consultation on changes to the
wider planning system and plan making at
the end of 2022 in terms of principles
and then we have this consultation where
we've got a response in front of you
today which started at the end at the
end of July
2023 so for local plans they've now
published proposals that change both the
way that plans are prepared preped
examined and adopted and also proposals
for the way the content of those plans
the substantive content of those plans
as well so it's the two elements of the
process and the
content this is all underpinned by a
vision that the government sets out in
the consultation and I think they're
laudable aims I don't think any of us
can disagree with them for plans to be
simpler to understand and to use we know
the length of our local plan 500 pag
it's not an easy read um it's it's it's
a big verbose document to be positively
shaped by the views of communities about
the how their area should evolve it's
it's a very sensible thing we want the
area to be responsive to the needs of
our communities we want to hear their
voices we want to make sure that they're
engaged in that process and that they've
got ownership about the way that their
area develops in the
future that it clearly shows what is
planned for the local area so that it's
articulated in a in an easy to
understand way way that it's uh that
it's it's visible it's it's using tools
that we got available to us uh to make
that easier for the communities to
understand it's in plain English uh and
Etc that they be prepared more quickly
and updated more frequently I think
we're all aware of how long it took us
to prepare the last local plan for North
de andage for various reasons not not
just the authorities uh got the blame on
on its door I don't think um but it took
very long time so I think we can all
agree that there's a sense in trying to
speed up that process and for plans to
be prepared more frequently um we know
that we're in a in a very different
world now to when the plan system was
put in place things change more rapidly
situations change the world is much more
Dynamic than it was maybe when the
planning system was was
envisaged and to make the best use of
new digital technology I think um again
we we we can't can't argue with that
things are moving on extremely quickly
we've got amazing technology to allow us
to visualize things to allow us to
present information in different ways um
but we will come on to some of the
pitfalls of some of this as
well so an overview of the consultation
itself it follows on from that previous
consultation that looked at principles
at the end of 20122 which both councils
provided a joint response to um but this
consultation is more focused on the
detail and it's focused on how you go to
implement through legislation and
through policy the actual changes that
they want to bring into the to the plan
making system it's opened on 25th of
July and is open for a period of 12
weeks closing on the 18th of October so
this meeting is extremely timely to be
able to look at this response and then
allow us to finalize that and submit it
has 42 substantive questions across 15
different topic areas uh include and
then there's a 43rd question around
equality and
diversity importantly it doesn't seek
views on matters that are being taken
forward through the leveling up and
regeneration bill that's taking forward
the the primary elements of legislation
around the plan making reforms and they
are set aside from from the detail that
they're looking at for views on through
this
consultation so as I say it's a wide
ranging consultation but at the same
time it goes into an extensive and very
detailed level of of technical uh Nuance
in terms of what they're looking to do
in terms of the process and in terms of
what they would suggest is going into
plans it covers plan form and plan
content so the way I look a plan will be
constructed and also the detail of what
would go in it looks at the process of
plan making and how that would go about
and also the timetable and the
sequencing for plan making as well it
moves into into evidence and what we
would need around that and also the
approach to
engagement it looks to reform our
approach to monitoring around Authority
monitoring reports and change that and
the process and make a more light touch
approach to that and also provides us
with some transitional Arrangements
which we do have some concerns around
they're also looking to Pilot something
called Community Land auctions um which
is a different way of capturing land
value through the planning system to put
towards infrastructure
Etc so the key points that we've raised
on the consultation um which is set out
in appendix one to to your report um is
that the principles are broadly sensible
and loable we we think that what they're
proposing um generally has an inherent
sense to it as as we were saying at the
start there around those vision and and
aims from from the
government and the response broadly
offers support subject to some caveats
for for the following elements A Renewed
emphasis on Vision Le planning um so
that you're focusing right at the start
on developing a locally specific Vision
um and that that then drives your
approaches and your policies through the
whole of that local plan and that it
articulates where you want to go for
your area in the future a loable aim we
do have some concerns that we raise
through that draft response around uh
the expectation that you establish that
Vision right at the start of your
process and they they suggest that you
won't do your evidence Gathering to a
certain degree until later in that
process what we're suggesting is that
it's actually en visioning is is an
iterative process and that you need to
have regard to that evidence so we've
highlighted that as part of the
response targeted local development
management policies um seems very
sensible at the moment lots of local
plans will be repeating the same thing
possibly with slightly different wording
just replicating what's in National
planning policy and applying that local
wording to
it the suggestion is that they will have
a suite of national development
management policies that's one of the
elements that's not up for debate
through the consultation and is taken
forward through the legislative changes
to the leveling up and regeneration
bill but that we will be able to have
local development management policies in
our local plan to deal with locally
specific issues seems very sensible we
have however raised concerns that we
have should have the opportunity to
deviate from those National policies
where we think there's justification and
local reason to do so that's not
something they're suggesting you're able
to do at the moment so we've pushed that
as a as a matter through through that
response we think that's particularly
important we've also raised the fact
that it's important for the government
to make sure that the policies are rural
proof
to to reflect the different context that
we may have in our area compared to
other areas of of the
country increases in use of
digitalization uses of templates that
they're suggesting are produced um and
that's both for parts of process such as
getting information about sites but also
for different elements of the plan
they're suggesting there are templates
for Visions for policies for the way you
set out your objectives for the way you
do your monitoring um all very laudable
all seems very sensible again if we can
streamline the processes if we can
streamline and get some consistency in
the way that plans look it seems very
sensible and that goes on to that third
Point around
standardization we have raised some
concerns around digitalization and
making sure that that isn't at the
detriment of certain sectors of our
community that may not be so ofay with
digital tools and and accessing
information in a digital Manner and the
need to make sure that we've got that
balance there still from from a template
perspective whilst it's laudable in
terms of I think time saving and
consistency it also needs to be a point
that it doesn't stifle Innovation um a
lot of of great work a lot of of
progressive work happens through local
plans and that happens through being a
bit Dynamic and pushing the boundaries
so we want to make sure that by
introducing templates we're not stifling
that so we've made made that point and
the same with standardization that
actually if they're bringing the these
things that the templates are available
at day one the software is available at
day one otherwise the very demanding
time tables they're talking about for 30
months plan preparation are going to be
even more challenging and actually plan
making may take longer by having to
transition to those tools rather than
shorter as they would
wish they're suggesting clearer
expectations on evidence
requirements um again I think that's a
very sensible uh and Lord will aim name
we all know and anyone who attended the
local plan examination or has been into
any of our meeting rooms will see the
volumes of paper information that we
have that supported the preparation of
the last local plan and that is a very
timec consuming element of plan
preparation and that evidence is often
subject to detailed challenge by Third
parties as well so getting clearer
expectations on what that evidence might
be and the quantum and type and amount
of evidence that you might require and
standardizing that through guidance
again has to be a sensible and laudable
aim I think one of our concerns was that
they were suggesting that you wouldn't
have all of that evidence then submitted
to the examination and that it would
only be that evidence that was required
to demonstrate your plan is legally
compliant and sound would need to be
submitted we have concerns about how you
select that evidence and how you would
cherry-pick that from your bigger
portfolio of evidence that you required
to decide on your vision Etc um and
concerns that you may not have put
forward evidence that would legitimately
show your plan is robust um so we we we
we raised some concerns around that
aspect of the
proposals improve improve project
management
expectations um making use of a project
initiation document which is good
project management practice uh it's
something that we did for our last local
plan it's something that we prepared at
the start of the people and place
project so it's something that we've
been doing anyway and should be good
practice they're looking to streamline
that but introduce that as as part of
the the prerequisite process of
preparing a local plan alongside Gateway
reviews where you will have an external
check up key points on how your plan is
progressing including a final one of
those which is a stop go to whether or
not you can move through to
examination again they all seem laudable
sensible elements to take forward
through planning reform we do have some
concerns around resourcing the Gateway
assessments and that that could in
increase the amount of Burden that's
placed on local authorities but we do
recognize that they probably have a
value as well but I think that goes back
to the concerns around the 30-month time
frame for preparing a local
plan there's a new requirement to assist
and that's around prescribed public
bodies such as the environment agency
Natural England that they are um
required to support us when we go to
them to ask for information or ask for
their views and perspectives um it can
be a challenge we've been quite
fortunate but it can be a challenge to
to get information from statutory bodies
in a timely manner and to get get a a
definitive view this is intended to um
require them on a statut basis to do so
and to provide us with that information
when required and when when requested we
do have some concerns that we've raised
around that is that they're suggesting
that that's a back stop requirement and
therefore it's a a requirement of Last
Resort um it seems to me that it would
be sensible that it's actually more
prescribed than that uh and that
actually it's a it's just a requirement
that's placed upon them to to to
actually assist us throughout the whole
process and then rationalized monitoring
requirements at the moment we have to
prepare an authority monitoring report
every 12 months
uh there's a suggestion that actually
that moves to a much more light touch
set of statutory uh metrics that we just
have to report on around things like the
amount of houses that are completed the
amount of employment floor spaces
completed the amount of public open
space that is gained or lost for example
alongside uh information on planning
obligations amount of uh money that we
receive through section 106 is amount of
land
Etc again seems a very laudable and
sensible prop position Authority
monitoring reports haven't necessarily
been effective um would would be our
view um and it seems much more sensible
to streamline that and then after four
years they're suggesting that as part of
your plan review process similar to what
we've had presented to you through the
earlier item today you would do a much
more comprehensive and detailed
assessment of how your plan is
performing there are some schizophrenic
elements in terms of their proposals
there around that um in that they are
talking about making sure in earlier
parts of the consultation that you have
a a detailed and robust monitoring
framework supporting your plan and then
they're suggesting that on the other
hand you only need this lighter touch
set of metrics so we have raised those
those tensions between some of those
proposals uh in through the through the
draft response but again it seems Seems
sensible and and
laudable so there're the elements that
we think were um very sensible uh and
the
as a council and from our professional
opinion and from attending an online
event and also an inperson event with
government Representatives through the
planning advisory service that our
understanding is that they would be very
s sensible elements to take forward and
to the benefit of our councils there are
some other elements however that we do
have some concerns around um the
sequencing of the plan making process
they're setting out a very prescribed
staged process that they suggest
um we're suggesting that actually plan
making isn't that linear in the way that
it goes about that it is iterative in
that you do end up having to step
backwards you do have to prepare
sometimes further Evidence um and that
you need to take that into account in
terms of that process you need to be
able to revise and adjust your vision as
you go forward and you take account of
some some of that evidence your policies
may need to
change the approach to Gateway
assessments um we think that again
they're very sensible but there's some
there's a few challenges with them for
example it's they're suggesting that for
the uh earlier Gateway assessments
Gateway assessment one where you check
at your vision um and Gateway two where
you're looking at your draft policies
and the emerging policies that you only
identify five issues that you may have
with your with your plan it seems to me
more sensible that actually you should
be identifying any concerns that you
have with your plan to be reviewed
through that Gateway necess for them to
have value that you should be
identifying all of those concerns to get
that external body to have a look at
them that's where you would add value to
it rather than having an arbitrary
number for example that
identified uh reductions in some periods
of notifications and consultation well
say suggesting that the first
consultation around the vision is
extended to eight weeks from six weeks
compared to what we have in the in the
process at the moment uh during the
examination process they're suggesting
that notification of hearing sessions is
reduced to only three weeks which could
be a concern for statutary bodies could
be a concern for Paris councils who may
wish to attend for example or for
individuals who may have other
arrangements to try and make in order to
attend part of that is is offset by
allowing written representations to be
submitted and heard in in your absence
at the hearing sessions but do have
concerns particularly for for elements
of our community and staty stakeholders
that that that would be challenging
equally for the consultation on any any
major modifications that may come
forward through the process again
they're suggesting that that is reduced
uh and halfed from the six weeks that
was previously taking place to allow
people to have their say again if Paris
councils and their timings of their
sequencing and even uh neighboring
authorities Etc statutory bodies they
may find that extremely challenging in
providing substantive and sensible
responses to it so we've raised
that that risk of disenfranchisement
through digital engagement with our with
our local communities and making sure
that it's not at the detriment of those
people that we really try hard to engage
um digital isn't the answer to
everything and then we rais fundamental
concerns although it's not a matter
that's directly through the consultation
around the realism of of a 30-month time
frame for delivering a plan from end to
end um and that includes the examination
and that includes the adoption and in
particular there's elements around only
having one month after you received the
inspector's report to finalize your plan
which may include making adjustments and
modifications to it taking it through
your Democratic processes uh and getting
it to adopt publication one month seems
extremely tight in in terms of that
aspect of it and similarly with the 23
months that they're proposing to go
through from a standing start for your
plan making to actually having a
finalized plan submitted to to
examination now they have listened and
they have introduced a four-month period
at the start of that that's beyond that
four 30 months um so taking it to at
least 34 months uh but that's about
early engagement work that's about
notification um with with with other
bodies so we do have some concerns
around that and we have raised those
around that achievability particularly
as the main elements that take the time
around evidence Gathering engagement Etc
haven't really
changed and then we've raised
fundamental concerns around the
prescribed transitional Arrangements um
and in particular the suggestion of
constraining the timing of when You' be
able to start your plan update or
Preparation of your new plan they're
suggesting that they're going to adopt a
wave approach where they will put local
authorities into waves of 25
authorities uh and they will start plan
making every six months and you'd be
ordered by how old your plan is so those
with the oldest plan would be able to
start their plan making first given that
we're in the uh top 27% I think it is of
local authorities that have a plan
that's less than 5 years old it could be
some significant time before we were
able to start any new plan making uh
under that regime so it could be a
number of years before we would have
that opportunity under their proposals
so we've raised significant concerns
about that and recommended that either
that's a back stop date uh in terms of
of when you can start or that you should
have that discretion to look at what it
is locally and what's right for your
local communities uh as to when you
should be starting that plan
making so chair the recommendations are
set out on page 126 of the report if
you're looking at the torage agenda or
127 if it's the north Devon version of
the agenda and uh they they are for the
committee to consider the draft response
which is set out in appendix one and
then to endorse the response to be
formally submitted on behalf of North de
Council and Tor District Council and at
that point I'll hand back to you chair
and happy to take any questions thank
you Ian you've clearly done a lot of
work on this
one now open for discussion first of all
anyone wishing to comment C councelor
hes thank you chair um yeah amongst the
list of sorry amongst the list of
responses you didn't include a concern
about the auction
system I don't think could you just
expand on that for you
chair uh I don't no I don't believe that
um there was if I recall a specific
question around that um there were
details in the consultation I believe um
but I don't believe that there was a
specific question where they were
seeking a response around it I thought I
read that there was you there are a
number of concerns that you had about it
in terms of the valuation of land Etc or
am
I am I dreaming Sor
right no CH I I apologize um yeah so we
we do have you're not dreaming councelor
hes um as you aware there there is a lot
of questions in there um yeah so in
terms of the response we welcome the
commitment to explore Innovative
approaches to land value capture an
uplift um but and we we do see the logic
in it but we do have some concerns about
how that would work in practice um and
whether or not you would actually be
able to capture that that uplift in in
in that value and how that would work um
whether or not there's the ability for
that system to be gamed I I think in
terms of that that initial price um for
those that are not aware it's about a
process of putting forward bids for land
to be included as allocations within
your local plan and that they would be
effectively closed bids um and they
would become binding values for the sale
of that land at a later date for that
for that land owner so they would be
committed to selling that land at that
that fixed price and then what would
happen is that a the council or a third
party would then be able to buy that
land and bid for that land at a later
date once it's allocated for an uplifted
value and then the land the difference
in that value would be able to be
captured um and used for the provision
of infrastructure Etc I think there's
some real concerns about land values
going up and down fluctuations of that
how do you ensure that that captures the
maximum value um how do you take account
of other aspects that aren't just value
based around what's the best site um is
it going to influence and and and sty
some of that sustainability
considerations Etc um so count councel
hes is correct we I I didn't mention
that in in my presentation but we do
cover that in in the
response yeah for explanation um the
other general question um there's some
very valid points responses that you've
made um we've just gone through um do we
know is there a sort of unified response
across local authorities uh do we know
what the local government Association
response is for instance I mean our
response would be stronger if we tie in
with with that I'm just
interested chair for M um I I haven't
seen a local government Association
response I think uh having having
discussed with uh planning professionals
and having attended uh an event put on
by by uh dck and planning advisory
service um myself and and Helen attended
uh I I think there's a general consensus
around most of the points that we're
making through this this and certain Al
the the attendees at that event in
exiter they were the the civil servants
from duu who are actually working on
these proposals and that they were
genuinely trying to listen to to what
local authorities and others were having
around the concerns and they do have a
an ambition to make it work and and to
make sure that the proposals do work for
for local authorities and for
communities whilst also recognizing the
the government's drive and and Direction
and and
vision
councelor James thank you chair
um yeah thank you for the officers is
this the report that you've already
commented on the one we looked at the
other day or is this the new comments so
the date for submission of this is the
18th it's the 18th of octob all right so
that's not the one we done the other day
right could I ju Just from my our side
or my side um on the vision um I take
the point you're making um but obviously
we've to just done a strategic plan or
we're working on a strategic plan and
with other uh groups like
The me the Devon Futures people like
that we are looking at how we are going
to drive forward the area with a vision
for whole of Northern Devon in terms of
economy and meeting some of the
requirements on hosing and all that so I
think we've got some of that evidence of
what we want to do um I'm not sure how
it ties in with North Devon but we can
have a separate meeting about that are
strategic against what you're looking at
um and that we get a balance that we
have a vision but I think we generally
agree we have a vision to improve the
the the future for our young people in
particular in terms of education
employment skills opportunities and the
one that we'll keep them here is housing
um which we do need to address and it's
just not more hosing it's specific
hosing how we deal with that um I think
I like the bit where you commented on uh
local policies being part of it or local
aspirations that we can do through local
plan and stuff like that neighborhood
plans um the early monitoring is just
extra work um you know a light touch
would be far more sensible um I just
wrote best of luck with the outside
bodies knowing what the EA and the um um
the Natural England and all those are
like um the five monitoring fouryear
monitoring should give us an opportunity
to check that we are on the right track
rather than getting to the end and then
thinking we've missed something um the
land value thing I think is almost
impractical but we're waiting to see the
the more details but um we are with that
the limited number of gateways could be
an issue but you know we have got around
that number that we're looking at but we
it it would be better if it wasn't
specific to that number
um and there was the last one oh about
the waves and that um the our chief exec
myself were meeting
with the government Minister for
leveling up next W week Wednesday um
because obviously um there is an
opportunity for torage under the
deprivation funding to actually apply
for funding for specific areas that we
want to improve some of those will
overlap with North Devon so it's not
just torch it will be a torage driven
but there will probably be some overlap
and one of the things we will be talking
to him about is our need to get on with
a local plan a new local plan um
assuming that's where we're going um in
order to deliver the stuff we want to
deliver within the leveling up
partnership and that is what this is the
deprivation fund is really being called
is the leveling up partnership between
specifically torch as a whole
and um the government of the rules we
started to have a reasonable discussion
with um under the previous Minister
which was Dian Davidson um but she
stepped down and we know we're dealing
with Jacob young and we're not sure
where that's going to go we don't know
whether we're going to get a pound or 20
million we have no idea at the
moment um so I think the thing with the
waves is that we need need to really
respond that in order to capitalize and
all we need to do and and the
deprivation is not just Tage you know
you've got areas in North Devon that you
need to deal with and so we need to get
this picture of a vision of Northern
Devon all of us working together to get
that across the government and the
funding we need to be able to achieve
that and it's not just the funding it's
the vehicle which will be the local plan
and also the other thing is the
transition from where we are now to when
we deliver a local plan how do we deal
with the bits that we could probably
advance and can we use those before we
actually get to the full
adoption so that's my little bit thank
you
chair right oh it come to the pros first
chair I'm trying to get my head around I
mean we know we know that there the
certain reforms are
coming because they're in the in the
main Bill whereas this is stuff that's
just going to be signed off by the
minister am I right is that yeah yes so
this this could come forward through a
series of the regulations Associated to
the leveling up and regeneration bill
which should become act um so we're told
by sometime in November all being well
um before the end of this session of
parliament is is the
intention um or through policy changes
or through guidance changes so it'll be
a series of regulations policy and
guidance
changes so as long as there's not an
election in May the likelihood is that
these are going to be
enacted is that an unfair question to
ask you I I I I think that's a bit of
Crystal B gazing to be fair but um C
certainly I think we got the impression
that there is a a drive to push forward
these these aspects of it and to get
them in place um through the
early adoption of the leveling up and
regeneration bill as an act in November
and then they seem to have an ambitious
program around the regulations and the
policy changes that they would be
looking to then get in place next year
to be in that position to start in
November 2024 with the substantive
changes to to to plan making because I
wanted to pick up on Ken's point about
deprivation I mean we've got a real
issue at the moment we we've had a
debate in our Council last week and
before strategy committee about our
inability to get intervention in Africa
that has got the worst figures of of of
any locality in the whole of the county
which has been recognized by the County
Council as well so we're with you
completely Ken on that um what the only
reason I ask those questions is it you
know this time scale worries me we need
to get our act together in terms of
strategic plans there's still a lot we
can do without changing the local plan I
think and I think we it'd be great to
get a debate about that what we can do
um without waiting the end of five years
or four years or however long it it ends
up being so I'm I I too wanted to say
what a super bit of work and I I read in
detail the bit of work that you and your
colleagues when both authorities put
forward on the permitted development
right changes and all those other
changes and you know we we're doing a
lot of really good detailed work here
and I just wanted to say thank you to
both sets of staff on that chair but i'
I'd mve the recommendation that we
support um the presentation and the
responses on the agenda today as our as
our response to the government's
consultation
chair seconded second that chair yeah
got it councelor
hes
con amount of time for consultation with
the local commun unities really I think
you pick out at certain points on
modifications for instance um your the
concern about lack you know the shortage
of time for consultation which you know
seems to go against the whole the whole
EOS a more open you know scrutiny really
so I hope you know it's good that we're
emphasizing
that I've got
oh councelor Warden sorry thank you
working right um I just wanted to really
Echo what um councilor PR has U um said
because um we do have this real problem
with Elum and the deprivation in that
particular area um and I also wanted to
Echo um what he had to say about all the
hard work that uh us officers have have
done in preparing the response my one
concern of course is that um uh
this might actually happen anyway
because if we have this general election
next year um the whole situation could
change totally but I mean we can't do
anything about that except uh the pallet
Bo when the time comes but um obviously
I'm supporting um what you've put
forward U because I think it is the way
forward um at this particular stage but
we may be looking in 12 months time at
doing something totally different thank
you councelor room I suppose I better
just put on record chair echoing what
Ken was saying about our strategic
corporate objectives as a council for
North Devon we're going through the same
process and all members have all met and
um I'm sure if we had a crystal ball if
we looked at those priorities they'd all
be the same around um housing around
keyw work and accommodation to be honest
um and lots of other other other issues
I mean the main the main highlight for
us is ilu throughout the whole of Devon
life expectancy in in ilum is 10 years
less than than than than most other
places um child poverty is
39.8% which is you know a a vast amount
more than places in in exitor um so um
we have got a real big issue in in in in
North Devon with with um Health
inequalities especially so um and we we
two are making represent representations
to the leveling up Minister and I'm sure
that um our two Chief executives are
talking to each other to ensure that we
don't duplicate and and and and acting
as one we can be more forceful coming as
a northern Devon area rather than
looking at our side and your side
actually we're all one side to be honest
and um actually we're a bigger we're a
bigger voice together
so councilor
leather thank you chair I'll Echo what
council room just said there about us
working together on this and is
important that we do as one Northern
Devon um The Wave these waves I'm a bit
worried about that because I think to
start to start a new local plan should
really be determined by the fact of the
need to start in which there is in my
view a need to start a new local plan
the process as soon as we canel I'm
worried about this wave thing because
we're com it's a comparatively new plan
we've got I don't want to be put to the
back of the we years to start it
there there is an urgency to it for some
of the reasons counc rooms mentioned and
also councelor James in the economic
side of things for Norther Devon um
and and I know there's a bit
of worry about this consultation not
having come to the counselors earlier
since it was launched in July but I tell
you what when you look through the
amount of work that's got to be done to
respond to this consultation I certainly
wouldn't like to do do it I've tried to
read through all of it and I've given up
partway through with some of it and gone
back to it and picked things out again
so you know I Echo what council PR said
about the staff who've done a brilliant
job in responding to this consultation
you know I'm I should definitely be
supporting it
wholeheartedly thank you I canel HS
again chair they yeah they have done a
brilliant job but I mean the same
concern is relates to this consultation
as to the permitted development one we
we should have been given more time as
counselors to look at it I think thank
you just as defense we we did have an
outline of this back at our informal
meeting as well so I think we were aware
of some of the concerns initially so I
just you know want to put that point so
it's not last minute as as some might
imagine no the the only comment I would
make is the wave
problem
um I can't really envisage that we need
to get HR involved and put staff on
gardening leave because it's put to a
standstill uh therefore I can only
assume some way we'll find a get way to
get it
done but right I've got it proposed and
seconded that um we accept these
uh uh observations as put forward by our
staff can I have a show of hands
please that is easy that is
unanimous thank
you
um we now move on
to item 10 item 10 yeah we got farther
than I expected suggested date of a new
new meeting of the next meeting 8th of
December 10:00
a.m. trust that clashes with nothing
important councelor
room yeah of
course um a very good potentially a
problem over here in Tor our treasure is
very
tight I'll sure the chair will sort that
out I can't afford the Christmas stamps
that's certain right I think can I just
com can I just come in on the yes
certainly yeah thank you we can
certainly arrange Mt pies um just um
just to say
for the next meeting we've already got a
very sensible suggestion from councilor
prow that we look at the Gypsy and
traveler matters at that meeting um what
we can also have a discussion around and
and officers will agree the content of
the agenda with the chair and vice chair
in advance is just of maybe looking at a
forward plan as to what this committee
can usefully be doing over the coming
the coming year um you know a big a huge
message that came across that the the
stuss Ian Liz and I went to was the
importance of visioning that shared
vision and you know I think we can
certainly be looking And discussing
around some of these issues which you've
already raised today so we we will
certainly try and look and make sure
we've got you know a productive series
of meetings to to move move us all
forward with sort of planning policy
matters across across both
councils okay thank you and I think I
can declare the meeting closed not by
that clock but by my wife watch at 12
minutes past
that